en las últimas horas durante la
madrugada se reportaba la crecida de
ríos y la caída de puentes en algunas
partes del país
managua en los departamentos aledaños
son los que han sufrido serias
inundaciones durante las últimas horas
las autoridades advierten que las
próximas horas seguirán lloviendo y que
el peligro aún es latente en la mayor
cantidad de lluvia ha caído en la zona
del pacífico y occidente del país y
hasta ahora el gobierno afirma que los
fallecidos son seis personas pero esta
cifra podría aumentar en las próximas
horas debido a que las probabilidades de
deslizamientos de tierra que provocarían
las lluvias persistentes en el país como
remanente de yota podrían aumentar
significativamente esta cifra hasta el
momento se reportan más de 30 hospitales
con daños estructurales y unas 63 mil
personas refugiadas en albergues